Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the NCBI Minute.
This is the first one of these we've done as a webinar.
My name is Peter Cooper; and with me this morning is Tao, who is manning the questions pod.
The idea behind these NCBI Minutes is that they should be very brief webinars that are basically designed
to introduce you to an NCBI resource that you might not be familiar with
or to give you a tip about using one that you already are familiar with but there is some trick
that we don't think you know about that might make your life easier.
The sort of business things are up here on the slide.
We will make a video recording of this and all of our webinars.
I just wanted to remind everybody that we do have a YouTube channel,
and the address of our YouTube channel is there with a link to the playlist section.
So we'll have a webinar playlist, and some of these webinars may be cross-posted with other playlists that we have;
for example, BLAST.
Since this is a short webinar, I'm not going to have time to really address questions orally during the webinar;
so put them in the questions pod.
Tao will answer ones that are quick; he types fast.
Ones that take a little longer to respond to or ones where we have to look for the answers,
we will get back to you on that.
We'll put those things up, and they'll link them to the Webinars page.
And the URL for our new version of our Webinars page is there at the bottom of this slide.
This is a link to our Learn button that's on the front of our Home Page now.
This morning we're going to talk about a utility called MOLE-BLAST.
MOLE-BLAST is a way of clustering sequences and finding their nearest neighbors in the NCBI sequence database.
It then makes a phylogenetic tree of those sequences.
And what's it's good for is for working with what I'm going to called targeted sequences.
We often call these things targeted loci.
These are things like ribosomal RNA genes from bacteria or fungi
or even things like cytochrome oxidase 1.
It uses BLAST to do the initial clustering and generates a multiple alignment using MUSCLE and then a phylogenetic tree.
People who use this could be people like taxonomists, people who are interested in evolutionary biology,
people who are doing ecological studies with metagenomes.
And of course we use it here to confirm identifications and to see if something might be misidentified.
Certainly people that submit to the NCBI can use this tool to identify their own sequences
and confirm that they are what they think they are.
The materials and the examples that I'm going to use are linked to the FTP site, and they're in there.
And I'm going to go ahead and go now to the BLAST Home Page and then link to MOLE-BLAST.
So let me go ahead and do that here.
Actually, I think what I'm going to do is escape from my slide set and we'll just go there directly.
Let me go ahead and do that.
What I'm going to do is go over here; and this is the NCBI Home Page, of course.
And if you go to our BLAST Page, if you scroll down,
MOLE-BLAST is linked down here in our Specialized BLAST section of the page.
And I'm going to go ahead and follow the link to MOLE-BLAST.
MOLE-BLAST lets you submit a list of nucleotide accessions or FASTA formatted sequences,
and it gives you some guidelines as to how big those can be.
And so we're going to go ahead and pick a set from the NCBI databases and do that real quickly.
The one that I'm going to use over here that I have already loaded in one of my tabs --
and this is available on the FTP site -- this is a set of clones that were identified
or 16S ribosomal RNA genes that were sequenced from one of our PopSets.
And this is from a waste water metagenome.
And so what you can quickly do on an Entrez page like this is go ahead and set the display to Accession List,
hit Apply, and then I have a set of 50 accessions that I could quickly just grab, copy them,
and throw them into MOLE-BLAST.
So I'm going to paste those in there, and then I can run this.
Let me just go over a couple of settings here, and we'll probably have time to do just the one example this morning.
But I just want to show you how this works.
I could search against the default NR database,
and that's going to be useful if I'm using one of the non-targeted sequences
or one that we don't have a separate database for.
Notice that I can pick right now the 16S ribosomal RNA sequences that we have as a reference collection.
And those are the ones that I would want to use to try to identify these unknown organisms
or partially-identified organisms that are in this set.
So I can pick that as my database.
And then notice like on the regular BLAST page, there are some advanced parameters here.
I can choose my Search program.
I'm going to use Megablast; it's faster.
It picks a set of sequences for me.
It can also exclude things.
If I'm going to search against the NR database, it might be useful to exclude uncultured sample sequences
because they won't give me much in the way of confirming my identification.
Also notice that I can check this "Sequences from type material" box, which is very useful.
When we search our 16S rRNA database,
what you're going to find is that many of those are going to be from type material.
And that would give you some confirmation about the identity of the organism involved.
MOLE-BLAST will cluster query sequences by loci -- what those loci often are,
are going to be different genes if you have a mixed set.
In many cases, the cluster is going to be governed by how good your sequences are, how long they are,
and what the quality of the alignments are as well.
We can adjust those parameters.
For example, this example that I'm going to do right now, you could go back and you can play around with this
and see if you can change the number of clusters by changing the percent identity.
One thing that's very helpful to do with MOLE-BLAST because we don't have an Edit and Resubmit
is to hit the "Show sequence results in new window" and rerun it.
I'm going to go ahead and just submit that.
But because MOLE-BLAST takes a couple of minutes to run, I'm just going to go ahead
and get the results because I have them stored.
So I'm going to go back here to my Submission Page and hit the Recent Results tab here.
Notice that MOLE-BLAST stores RIDs exactly the same way that BLAST does.
So I'm just going to retrieve one; I've got them saved here in a little text pad so I can remember what they are.
I'm just going to copy that one.
[Copying]
And retrieve my results.
And so the default display is to show you a tree based on that multiple alignment.
This one would be very useful if I was interested in knowing, for example,
the kinds of taxonomic units that were in my environmental sample.
And I can see on the right-hand side, they are color coded here by major groups of bacteria or the classes of bacteria.
From this page, I can also get to the tree itself and download it in some formats that I can work with locally.
I can also see an alignment.
If I click here, I can get to the MUSCLE based Multiple Sequence Alignment; so there it is.
This is a large number of sequences.
We had 50+, the database sequences that I'd asked for.
Many of these NR sequences here are going to be our reference collection of 16S ribosomal RNA sequences.
I notice from this page I can also edit and resubmit this to run MUSCLE again. [Since this webinar, the Re-align option was removed]
If I decided there were some sequences that I don't want to include, I can remove them
and realign the whole thing by going up here to the top and just realign them.
Let me go back to the tree view here.
If you're familiar with our tree view, all the same functionality exists here that exists on the BLAST pages.
I can display smaller sections of the tree, and I can splice smaller sections of the multiple sequence alignment.
I think that's all we really have time for today.
I just wanted to make sure that everybody knew about MOLE-BLAST and how to get to it and what you can do with it.
There are some additional examples that are available on that file on the FTP site.
And so that's the conclusion basically of one of these NCBI Minutes.
They're intended to be fairly short.
We'll have another one next week on the 15th.
Like I said, we don't have time to answer questions orally; but if you put them in the Questions pod,
we will try to get them and get them up on a document on the Webinars Page.
Thank you very much for coming to the first NCBI Minute.
Make sure that you check out our YouTube channel
and subscribe to that so you can see whenever we put new videos up there.
They're not going to just be the webinar videos.
There will also be individual recordings of how to do things and other types of things like that.